Allah Allah şunu söyleyeyim
bu düzeni evreni altüst etmek
istiyorsanız
ve hatta odanıza altüst etmek
istiyorsanız işe kendinize başlayın
sorun şu kendinizi altüst edebiliyor
musunuz edemiyor musunuz bana sorarsanız
ve yaratıcılık dediğimiz süreçle
başlayalım Çünkü yaratılış tam anlamıyla
bir alt-üst oluşturur
bu en büyük yaratıcı kim
E tabii ki Tanrı değil mi tanrının yine
din kitaplarına bakarsak yaratıcısı
özelliği kadar önemli başka özelliği var
o nedir o da yıkıcılık tır yaratıcılığın
ilk ve en önemli adımı yıkıcılık tır
yıkıcılık ile başlamaz sanız yani Yerine
Neyi koyacağınız a kararlaştırma dan var
olanı
bu savurup atmazsanız yaratıcılık mümkün
değildir Bu yüzden bu yüzden yaratıcılık
aslında bir isyandır Hatta düşüncesiyle
bir isyandır her yaratıcının isyanı
açılan büyük bir kapısı vardır İnsanlar
neden yaratma yaratıcı olmaya
kalkıyorlar bir tek nedenle ölümü bu
aşabilmek ölümden sonrasına kalabilmek
türküsü Bu açıdan bakıldığında bütün
yaratma eylemleri tanrıyla rekabet etmek
demektir
ve bu yüzden de tehlikelidir Ben Yatılı
okulda okudum uzun yıllar erkek yatılı
Okulu'nda arada kaçmak milli bir spor
Bornova'da bir çadır Tiyatrosu gittik
dansöz seyredip geri geliyoruz bir
meydanda meydanda yaşlı bir adam yaşlı
bir adam Beyaz saçlı oturmuş ağlıyor
korkunç bir sesle 16 ya da 17 yaşındayız
o zamana kadar öyle bir ses duymadım
sonra
en iyi sekiz yıl sonra falan Yürüyeceğim
duyacağım işkence çeken insanların sesi
de ona benziyor ne yaşı var ne cinsiyeti
var ne de acısının nedeni var böyle bir
şekilde ağlıyor yanına gittik
bu ne oldu Niye ağlıyorsun falan dedim
kağıdım var kayboldu havuz açacaklar
diyor kağıdın var kayboldu havuz
atacaklar bir Havuzun başında oturuyor
ama havuz boş ve bir karış derinliği e
bu anlaşıldı ki kağıdı bulmadan adımın
ağlaması bitmeyecek sonra kağıdı bulduk
açtık okuyoruz
ve bu belge ve işte Bornova bilmem ne
muhtarlığında verilmiştir iş bu belgeye
haiz Hasan toprağın ölümü halinde bütün
defin işlemleri tarafımızca yapılacaktır
diyor adam yok sunmuş ve kimsesizmişim
Ben ona demişler ki eğer yoksul ve
kimsesiz sen sen ölünce seni görmezler
tıp fakültesinin kadavra buzunu atarlar
demişler kağıdı kaybetme
en korkunç bir şey değil mi Adam
ölmekten korkmuyor yok olmaktan korkuyor
Çünkü hepimizin de sonra mezar istiyoruz
niye Başımıza bir başına bir Kitabe
koymak için o Kitabe nedir ben buradayım
Beni unutmayın demek
en yaratıcı insanız kitap beni hiçbir
zaman Yıkılmaz
O yanında oturduk dört kişi hüngür
ağladı ko gece hayatımı alt üst oldu
ve her git Herkesin bir kutsal gecesi
var benim kutsal yaşa bu biridir dedim
ki yoksulların yaşlıların kadınların
çocukların Ağladı bir ülkede yaşamak
istemiyorum Bu nedenle şunu söylüyorum
da wendy bir kere daha yazmıştım
en umutsuz iki tane güzel kızı var
Bu öfke ve cesaret öfke kovanlara
dayanabilmek cesaret s değiştirebilmek
için
bu sabah kalkıp
o banyoya gidin ve yüzünüzü suyla değil
öfkeyle yıkayın
bu öfkeyle yıkarsın enerji
bu direnç
bu ve bilinç kazanırsınız geriye kaldı
önemli Bir diğer konu o da cesaret
cesaret olmazsa yaratmak mümkün değil
cesaret Çünkü korkarak da olsa devam
edebilme yeteneğidir ileriye
belirsizliğe riske doğru adım
atabilmektir bütün Cesur adamların
kadınların insanların ödü patlar ödü
patlayan Cesur insan yoktur
o cesaret sanıldığı gibi kişiseldir
Erdemli değildir Çünkü eksikliğinden
dolayı kimseyi küçümseyecek biz yani Sen
Cesur değilsin diye Herhangi birini
küçümsemek aşağıda bak mümkün mü Hayır
ama cesaretin varlığı cesaretin varlığı
bütün diğer erdemlerimiz için çok güçlü
bir taban teşkil eder o erdemleri havaya
kaldırır yüceltir eksikliği de tersine
dejenere eder Eğer yeterince Cesur
değilseniz bir süre sonra bu mesela
sevgi ve sadakat ınız buna kişisel
erdemdir uyumcu Laa ve köleliğe dönüşür
O bizim aradığımız cesaret
bu yürekten mi çok alan toplumsal ve
ahlaki cesaret dediğimiz türlü cesaret
Ama bu tür cesaret başkalarının
bu toplumun acı ve Dertlerine bizim
acımız ve derdimiz olmasada kucak
açabilmek kendi varlığımızı başka
varlıklara katabilmek o varlıkları kendi
benliğimizin içine alabilme becerisi
demek
bu Eğer böyle bir şeyimiz varsa
iyi yürekli dediğimiz varsa dünyayı alt
üst edebiliriz yaratıcılık her ne kadar
sanatla
abi bilimle bağdaştırılır sana hayatın
her safhasına uygulanabilen bir süreçtir
ve herkes tarafından da öğrenilebilir
ama yaratıcıların sahip olması gerekli
bazı özellikler var Bunlardan birincisi
sime rock
da merak
bu keşiflerin bilimin ve aşkın
kılavuzudur bu 3'üne merak olmadan
ulaşmak çok çok zordur Mehmet aynı
zamanda duygularımız içinde önemlidir
yine bir başka Usta'dan dahi den örnek
verelim Vinci köyünden Leonardo yani
Leonardo Vinci diyor ki bütün
hissettiklerimiz Aslında
bildiklerimizden gelir şimdi gördüğünüz
gibi bilmekle hissetmek arasında da
önemli bir şey vardır bir yaratıcının
kendinde olmasını bekleyeceği ikinci ve
önemli unsur tutkudur
o tuttu aynı zamanda kişiliğimizin de
tutkalı dır tutkusuz insanlar çoğu kez
de bir süre sonra dağılır yok olur
bu e***** ve dinamik eylemlerimizin
toplamına Tutku diyoruz Bu bakımdan
bütün önemli sanat yapıtlarının
gerisinde güçlü bir tutku vardır
başyapıtları biraz şöyle eşeğin altında
ciddi miktarda şehvet bulursunuz ama
tutkunun faturası da var
bir tutku
bu İngilizce nedir perşembe değil mi
Fransız nedir Siyon derseniz olur
Bu ikisi de ikisi de
o Latince patik Yunanca patoz kökünden
geliyor yani acı çekmek fiilinden
geliyor tutkulu kişi acı çeker yaratıcı
olmak istiyorsanız tutkulu olmalısınız
Tutku ise sizi acıya götürür Acı
çekmeden Hayatının bir bölümünü acılı
yerlerde geçirmeden yaratıcılık mümkün
değil hayatınızı ne zaman altüst etmeyi
düşünürsünüz acaba acıdan sonra altüst
etmek isterseniz acı methiyesi yapmak
istemiyorum ama acıyla kimse hafife
almamalı Çünkü acı bize
bu insanların
bu durumlarını nesneleri ama en çokta
kendimizi tanıyıp duyumsama yeteneği
verir
çok keskin bir biri bilinç hediye eder
kökeninde bütün yaratıcılık eylemlerinin
kökeninde yoğun ve tükenmez bir acı
vardır
da bırakalım acı yenelim özgürlüğü Er
yaratıcının sahip olması gerektiği ki
önemli kutsal kavrama özgürlük
özgürlüğümüz her zaman ağır saldırı
altındadır özgürlük her sabah yeniden
katılmak zorundadır anamıza babamıza
karımıza kocamıza çocuğumuz ahlaka
geleneği dine ve iktidara karşı her gün
her gün
bu özgürlüğü savunmak zorundasınız ve
onu geri almak zorundasınız özgürlük su
gibidir de su ve deniz gibidir de
bölünemez bir parçasından vazgeçmeye
kalkarsanız türlü Elden Gider
bu özgürlük En çok da
bu soluğa benzer Neden mi ancak
yitirdiğimiz de önemini anlarsınız soluk
söyledim günde kaç kez soğuk alıyoruz
bilmiyoruz ama bir bir kısa bir süre
almayalım ne kadar önemli olduğunu
hayatı olduğunu anlara anlarız
özgürlükten öyle Şimdi burada kişisel
hikaye anlatayım bir tanem bundan
asırlar önce Ankara'da 1 numaralı
sıkıyönetim askeri mahkemesinde
yargılanıyor 240 kişi öğrenciler öğretim
üyeleri yazarlar çizerler
bu sanatçılar gazeteciler aklınıza kim
gelirse herkes var karşı tarafta mahkeme
heyeti askeri Hakimler Bir de
başladığında faşist bir General var
arkada dev gibi bir İnzibat albayı var
40-50 kadarda Süngü takmış Jandarma
onlarda isbat sağlıyor öğrenciyi fazla
olduğu için sık sık şey çıkıyor arbede
çıkıyor sloganları ve bazı sözcüklere
çok alerjik ler
da başladı özgürlük geliyor hadi bir
özgürlükleriyle kalk ağzınızı kaparlar
olmadı dipçikle kaburga kırarlar Kaburga
kırığı korkunç bir şeydir diğer
arkadaşın dilini kesmeye kalktıklarında
hatırlıyorum Özgürlük Demek yasak
hastasın bu koğuşta Ateş Var ateş
düşürücü antibiyotik lazım ilaç
Getiriyorlar bakıyorsun son kullanma
tarihi geçmiş
Ama tabii ki yüzbaşıya Sor gösteriyorsun
Bunların son kullanma tarihi geçmiş
ertesi gün hapishane komutanlığından bir
piryağ yazı geliyor
ve bütün ilaçların son kullanma
tarihleri bir buçuk yıl ötelenmiş tir
biliyorsunuz ama doğru ilaçların bile
özgürlük şansı yoktu Ben çok iyi
öksüremiyorum ama bir arkadaşımız vardı
mükemmel öksürdü Öyle ki ona
bu Paris Barış Antlaşması'nın sorun 8 10
maddelik birer paragraflık bütün
şeylerini maddelerin öksürerek
da söyleyebilirdin
ama gelgelelim Mahkemesi salonunda 80 80
80 Sağ taraf Öz orta taraf Gür sol taraf
lük diye öksürüyor özgürlük özgürlük
çılgın gibi herkes kırıklığını
yırtarcasına özgürlük varsa söylüyor
anlamıyorlar ama biz duyuyoruz hayatta
çok var söyledim ama hiçbiri o günkü
kadar olağanüstü ü Yani bu şu içinde
söyle söylediğimi hatırlamıyorum işte
böyle bazen sözcük bile yasak sadece bu
değil bilgel zaman git zaman af şu bu
hayat biraz normalleşti bir gün
çalışıyorum odamdan salondaki
televizyondan Gelen sesi duydu biri
bu daha doğrusu bir kadın şarkı söylüyor
Ben özgürüm Ben özgürüm de tatlı bir şey
ben özgürlük olunca hemen kulak abarttım
geri gittim Baktım televizyonda güzelce
bir kız bir beyaz Atın üstüne binmiş
özgürlük timsali ve Ben özgürüm diye
şarkı söylüyor biraz daha bakınca ne
göreyim cep telefonu reklamı yapıyor
O bizim
ne kaburgası dilimizi Feda etmek etmeyi
göze aldığımız özgürlük için özgürlüğün
nasıl metal araştırdığını gördük
bu Özgür önemli her dem Öz metal
araştırılabilir dedim yatılı okul çocuğu
yatılı okullarda ağlamak zayıflık şeydir
göstergesidir
var ama gittim içeride hüngür ağladım
Ama bu suları geçirdikten sonra şunu da
söyleyebiliriz iyi yaratıcılığa hazır
mıyız Bana sık sık sorarlar Ne yapmak ne
olması gerekiyor diye iki şey bakarım
ben bir büyük Hayat yaşadım lı Aslında
bu olmazsa olmaz biraz da sinoptan Gazi
havalarından gelen bir şey
bu çünkü büyük hayat yaşamak serüvene
yakın varlığını tehlikeye attığım ölüm
tehlikesi atlattım bir hayat türünü
kimseye büyük hayat yaşasın diyemeyiz
serüven yaşa diyebilir miyim size ya
dersem gaddarlık olur Çünkü sevmen son
tahlilde kötü talihtir
bu yemeye binersin yola çıkarsın batar
adaya çıkarsın 30 yıl kalırsın alsana
Robinson kruzo alsana serüven herkes
izin büyük bir hayatı olamaz ama
yaratmak isteyen kişiliği kişinin
ilk öncelikle herkesin ama hayat
edilmesi gerekir şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
hayatımda yok olmayabilir insan doğuyor
sonra da ölüyor her da ki süren ediyoruz
bu hayat demiyoruz değil mi Ömür diyoruz
hiç kimseye Doğan birine uzun hayatın
olsun dediğimiz duyulmuş mu uzun ömürler
diliyoruz
Ben bir insanı çok uzun bir ömür
olabilir ama içine bir tek Hayat bile
sıkıştırılmamış olması mümkündür tersi
de doğru yani kısa bir ömüre birkaç
Hayat sıkıştı Rab ilmek de mümkün İyi de
hayatım
bu ne Hayat yaptıklarımızın toplamı
arkadaşlar verdiğimiz kararlar
yaptığımız seçimler Risk almak bak şu
yeryüzünün üstüne
çok küçük de olsa bir Çentik atabilme
dürtüsü hepimizin şurada yüreği varsa da
olanları bir kere koyuyor onun yanında
büyük bir saksı var Buna Vicdan diyoruz
erdemlerimiz orada boyatıp filizleniyor
ve büyüyor ama hepsi bir tek Erdem'den
merhametten büyüyor Merhamet bütün diğer
erdemlerimiz inanası sayılır
ve merhametli olursak Adil oluruz Adil
olmak Adalet duygusunu adalet duygusu
eşitlik gibi erdemleri yan yana getirip
bu hayat edinmek Hayat edilmek Bu yüzden
erdemli olmak demektir Mert merhametli
olmak demektir ama merhametli olursanız
hayatımızın alt üst olması büyük bir
ihtimal bunları her zaman yapabilir
miyiz bazen yapamaya biliriz başarmak o
kadar kolay değil başarmak anormal
normal olan başarısızlıktır ama
çabalamak önemli olan budur hayat
edilmeye çalışırsanız Erdemli insan
olursunuz Söyleyeceklerim bu kadar
Herkese iyi günler bizi